ich höre auf und wenn ich ein solches
Video hochlade dann ist das nicht
irgendein Quatsch sondern dann wird es
diesen Kanal nicht mehr so wie bisher
geben denn hier heißt es in Zukunft
thanks for giving warum wieso weshalb
das erfahrt ihr in diesem Video los
geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ja schon einmal habe
ich ein solches Video gemacht hier auf
dem Kanal
vor neun Jahren hieß es hier ich höre
auf mit Promi Talk und ab diesem Moment
war hier auch Schluss den Namen habe ich
damals beibehalten weiter hieß es
klicksum aber ich startete Videos mit
meiner Leidenschaft Wissenschaft und
jetzt ist es wieder an der Zeit und Zeit
ist genau das richtige Stichwort vor
einiger Zeit erst begannen dramatische
Veränderungen oder ich sage mal so wir
wurden uns deren gewahr wir stellten
fest dass es so nicht weitergehen kann
gerade hier auf kriegstum kam immer
wieder die Themen Klimawandel Umwelt und
alles in diesem Bereich die uns deutlich
machten wir sind ziemlich auf dem
falschen Dampfer den falschen Weg so
geht es nicht weiter weltweit dann kam
Corona jetzt der Ukraine Krieg und jetzt
fragen Sie hier vielleicht einige was
redet der da das eine hat doch mit dem
anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun und doch
all das ist vom Menschen verursacht wir
Menschen sind für den Zustand unseres
Planeten und unserer Gesellschaften in
vielen Teilen in vielen vielen Punkten
verantwortlich und da geht es nicht nur
um Umwelt oder Gesundheit eben sondern
auch um soziales Energie Missbrauch
Bildung und und und und und an so vielen
Ecken muss etwas getan werden wir stehen
an einer Zeitenwende und das beste ist
viele viele Menschen tun etwas um etwas
Gutes für unsere Welt zu tun und darauf
kommt es jetzt an sie zu unterstützen
denn irgendwann ist es zu spät diese
Menschen zu unterstützen ihre
Geschichten zu erzählen aber auch auf
Missstände aufmerksam zu machen das
werdet ihr in Zukunft hier auf dem Kanal
sehen es wird nicht mehr darum gehen
hier irgendwie große Reichweiten zu
erreichen um 100.000 Views und viele
Likes oder so etwas es geht um diese
Menschen die helfen die sich engagieren
die sich opfern oder die weil sie zu
Opfern wurden nicht mehr schweigen und
Handeln es geht um das Gute und die
guten das ist im Moment wichtig und das
ist mir im Moment wichtig bestimmte
Themen werden hier weiterhin auf
bekommen wie die Energie und
Verkehrswende ohne die unser Planet
nicht überleben wird aber als erstes
werden wir hier die Malteser mit ihrer
Ukraine Hilfe proud to help unterstützen
und darüber hier berichten wie es
weitergeht ehrlich gesagt ich weiß es
nicht sprich ich bin auf eure Hilfe
angewiesen engagiert ihr euch
ehrenamtlich findet ihr Projekte cool
und möchtet dass ich darüber berichte
kennt ihr besondere Menschen die hier
unbedingt vorgestellt werden sollten
schreibt mir an
CK oder CK at thanks forgiving.de und
ich werde mich darum kümmern gerne könnt
ihr den Kanal auch mit einer
Mitgliedschaft unterstützen das würde
mich sehr freuen und würde die Arbeit
etwas erleichtern es kommt der
Berichterstattung über die Projekte hier
zu Gute und sorgt damit dafür dass sie
bekannter werden die Werbeeinnahmen die
dürften hier in Zukunft wahrscheinlich
nicht so sprudeln aber das ist auch
vollkommen okay so ich freue mich also
sehr über jede Unterstützung damit ich
hier über das Positive berichten kann
über die Menschen die etwas bewegen
wollen allerdings eins wird bleiben bis
dann
bleibt dran